this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by policy genius
coors pure skillshare and expressvpn
more on that later let's get into the do
the honeydew
with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it
in the night pants studios i am ryan
sickler ryan sickler.com
ryan sickler on all social media the
podcast is the honeydewpodcast.com
make sure you are subscribed to uh the
youtube don't just be out there watching
hit that subscribe get those numbers up
and uh if you gotta have more episodes
every week you know we're doing the
patreon the honeydew with you all
where i'm highlighting the lowlights
with y'all it's only five bucks a month
if you sign up for a year you're getting
over a month of free episodes all right
and that community is growing and
growing and the stories are getting
crazier and crazier i can't
i'm telling you the emails i still have
weight and i've said it before or just
[ __ ] bonkers so um sign up for that
if you can afford it i know times are
hard for people right now
uh speaking of times are hard for some
people if you need musical instruments
you know i'm over here at the santa
monica music center
still not allowed to give lessons in
person and everything so if you need
instruments
or online lessons go to santa monica
music dot com
use the code honeydew they will waive
the registration fee
and give you one free lesson when you
sign up for a package
all right now if you're new to the show
what i say every week is we highlight
the low lights
these are the stories behind the
storytellers if you're part
of this community already thank you for
your support i love you all
it is a pleasure to introduce this guest
uh
first time on the honeydew here i'm very
excited to have him here trevor wallace
yeah welcome to the honeydew thank you
man it's uh it's an honor to be here as
a fellow
santa monica resident myself uh i love
that you
used to be used to be down the street
yeah it was great i
just there's birds hammered i don't know
that's a great combo but we'll be
out here doing it but yeah something
about the air out here is great
but uh it's so far from everything so
just packed up my ego and headed to uh
the valley
i went the other way i was sherman oaks
forever
yeah we went opposite ways dang see
you're the smarter man of this
i i mean i like the valley though people
love the [ __ ] on it i like the valley
everything you need is in the valley
yeah i mean parking especially now that
traffic is
is no problem yeah they got everything
it's just a bunch of like sushi places
and hookah shops yeah so if you
whatever you need they got it um well
before we get into what we're gonna talk
about today plug
everything and anything you'd like sweet
i also have a podcast called stiff socks
uh
comes out every wednesday just uh me and
my friend michael blaustein just ripping
back another uh comedian from new york
good times
just shooting the [ __ ] uh that's every
wednesday so it's a good time check that
out on
apple spotify youtube all that stuff but
yeah other than that the videos i put
out
usually i do mondays you so you do drop
them on a regular
uh i try to do one a week which um your
videos are so
like i i i'm sure you watch his videos
if you don't it's the funniest [ __ ]
[ __ ] i sit and watch your [ __ ] over and
over and tell you
it's funny cause you i've been in comedy
so long and i had never met you
yeah and then i met you on we did kill
tony tony together
and i had finally been like damn it and
and i haven't seen you again since
yeah i think i've seen you again since
like i don't know how that happens that
we don't all don't run in the same
circle at some point but everyone's so
busy
yeah i think well that was probably
probably about a year ago to be honest
it was right before the
bid hit but i um i knew of you and i
and i should know and you were such a
nice guy on kill tony and i was like i i
thought you were going to be like more
like
just throwing out jabs like because i
remember like you're supposed to roast
people and kill tony
and then i said something that was like
kind of like not mean but like a jab at
this guy and everyone's like yeah [ __ ]
that guy and then you were all nice and
i was like oh [ __ ] am i supposed to be
nice
i did it wrong oh but i didn't know i i
was like i thought i was all kind tony
yeah well i didn't know what was going
on
it's so funny with that show tony says
the boundary's so clean he's like
he's like very clear he's like if you
don't have anything to say just sit
there and shut up
yeah and and then the whole time okay
yeah i felt like i was like in class
like with a joke to like say
yeah and then i was like you know what
if i just shut up and never said it but
you know i don't want to overstep tony's
boundaries you know
but yeah that was that was neat that was
awesome that was like the first time
i mean that's like one of those marquees
that like have been on like some comedy
marquees but seen the one on the comedy
store marquee man i was like
that's funny the first time i've ever
been on there really yeah it was [ __ ]
i loved it that was not good yeah
thank you tony hinchcliffe yeah thank
you no i i love that show i used to
when i had a day job i used to just
watch kill tony on tuesdays like the
highlights of it
and just see what of my friends like ate
[ __ ] the night before that was like my
guilty pleasure also some of your
friends would actually
actually made it up and performed on it
oh yeah i mean i mean that was like
monday nights were just like if you
weren't
doing uh i used to go to the spot in
like west la for like that was my mic
spot the improv space but everybody else
would be like
going to potluck my own kid up a potluck
knew and killed tony so
the next day if i wasn't at the store
i'd see like who got up
and then you just like sit there and
like pettily like watch your friends eat
[ __ ] and you're like oh
yes i don't know that's just some petty
[ __ ] i used to like to do
but that's kind of like this industry we
were just like you'll pass them to the
back and give a hug and then like right
after if they tripped you're like
good yeah so uh we met on that
and uh i figured we're going with this
well i wanted to have you on because i
don't
know much about you i mean i i we were
just talking about how
your videos you're so out there and and
i'm more reserved too and you're like
yeah i'm not people think that's who you
are in person when they meet and you're
like oh i thought you'd be this crazy
[ __ ] yeah
i'm going to alter ego and [ __ ] i'm more
so like startled when uh like literally
walking across the street just when i
parked
these two guys were in a prius which is
not like a car you think guys be yelling
at you
but two dudes were just just the most
santa monica people ever just curly hair
thick glasses 25 years old probably
you're like dude you make the youtube
videos and i'm just like
yeah and then they're just like all
right and i was like cool
and then that was our separate way i
think they wanted more of like uh
confetti no i never know what this is
right yeah you see me outside they're
like honey dude i'm like what am i
supposed to yell to you when you're
passing by
yeah yeah yeah you know just plug your
own podcast
so yeah uh i'm pretty i wouldn't say i'm
like uh god i can't even think what is a
damn word right now
um it's that covered brain bro that's
that coveted brain you know
no i do feel like i've gotten dumber
with the pain knowing you're not
outgoing or you're not introverted is
what i was looking for
i feel like i'm more on the
international side but like how i
perceive myself online is like very like
out there
extrovert i believe the word is um yeah
if you listen to my podcast you know i
don't know a lot of words but um
yes i just feel like what i put out
there is very big and boastful and then
in real life i'm just like like you and
i was saying it's like i don't mind
eating it alone at a restaurant yeah
every meal like i'd rather put it back
in the corner yeah i'd rather
yeah there's nothing all right so where
you're from ventura county yeah
camarillo
city out there yeah yeah the outlets
yeah bro
that's them we said well it was
hornblowers back in the day but what is
it actually called
nasa's ventura harbor comedy club that's
a good little spot i love it is a great
spot that's
uh where i started when i was 17. i was
uh
they had like a comedy class there and
the guy randy lubus he's a comedy og
he's been running that club for like
nine years i think he
just left but uh yeah that's why i
started i was doing comedy there and
but what was life like growing up in for
you
up there it was a lot of the outlets we
would just go we'd take our allowance
money whatever that was like 20 bucks
for the month and then
just go to the outlets and either buy
like a you know nine dollar pretzel for
no [ __ ] reason or just like buy a
stupid shirt with like a world
industries logo on it and just
be stoked on that uh what do your
parents do
my dad's retired my mom is uh in
marketing and she does like freelance
writing for like food stuff what did
your dad do
he was in sales are they all from
california too my dad's from ohio my
mom's from northern california okay
so are you an only child i have an older
sister you do she lives in new york now
okay but i was born in uh illinois
i was there for two years my mom's like
it's [ __ ] cold it's not worth it
let's get back out of there and then
straight back to california so i was
like
uh illinois for like two years okay
yeah but we we grew up pretty close to
the ocean so it was like you know 15
20 minutes so spend a lot of time on the
beach a lot of uh
a lot of car rides with a little bit of
the marijuana
you're going to have early yeah how old
were you when you first got high
freshman in high school yeah which uh
were you a good student no i didn't pick
up my grades until like my s
like my like end of sophomore year my
sister got into college and she took me
to a party
uh up at cal poly in san luis obispo
when i was like a sophomore or junior
and i was like oh this is what college
could be like she took me to a college
party and i was like
this is [ __ ] great that's what made
you straight 100 i had zero other
priorities i saw that and i was like oh
the movies are real and obviously this
was a party school so it was a little
more fabricated but
it was just like we went from one party
to another party and i was just hammered
i'm just having the time in my life
if i want to [ __ ] up i better get my
[ __ ] together exactly yeah i need to
stop [ __ ] up so i can go [ __ ] up on a
higher professional
level so that's essentially what i did
and uh got my [ __ ] together my sophomore
and like junior year
and then got into uh san jose state
up in the bay area went there for film
and theater
so you said growing up you just get
bullied and
teased a lot because you had red hair
yeah well diet
no this is it kind of grew out so this
is all natural now but like as a kid it
was it was pretty bad it was like uh
like was it that that red that shiny red
when the sun hits it that bright yes
it was kind of like an auburn-ish tone
which doesn't make things any better
because my middle name is auburn
nah that's where trevor auburn wallace
yeah so and you know what's [ __ ] up
is on my license it says trevor auburn
wallace and then hair color says
auburn so dmv is having a [ __ ] field
day back there
just going in on me just doing the
double double
you know or they had like a typo and
then just worked out i just but brown is
good enough you know
any of that another drop of it's fancy
but it's like not one of those middle
names i can go by like if i go by auburn
wallace like i just sound yeah
yeah you got to have a monocle in all
time butler yeah exactly
so uh it was like kind of red it wasn't
like a santino type red but it was like
uh
you know it definitely in the sunlight
had that that beam so
in like sixth or seventh grade that
south park episode came out talking [ __ ]
about gingers
and it was just a wrap after that it was
just
it's just a wrap you know and like
anybody so i'm 28 so anybody in that
kind of like
i guess within like a you know like 10
year span of that
probably watch that episode so when that
[ __ ] came out it was like
it was just a license like [ __ ] on just
oh yeah like my monday was fine
tuesday whenever whenever south park
came out the next day
people walked in and they're like oh
[ __ ] and there's like three gingers out
of school you know i think that was like
maximum for our school they're like you
got to cut it off here
too many gingers you gotta send them to
a [ __ ] board
yeah exactly so uh it was just like i
remember walking into school and i
hadn't seen the episode
and just fingers just pointed at me
across the yard oh you hadn't seen it i
didn't see the episode
i didn't know why this is happening but
i'll take was like somebody be like you
didn't see
[ __ ] soul park last night and i was
like exactly yeah
but like i wasn't like my parents
restricted me a good amount growing up
so
in what ways like they probably wouldn't
let me watch south park they'd be like i
would have to watch south park at a
friend's house or they'd be like why
don't you just watch the simpsons it's
more so simpsons were okay i love the
simpsons yeah they were okay with that
yeah because what other restrictions did
you have what would you say there was a
really funny one that was we couldn't
have
cereal that had over seven grams of
sugar in it i wanted to ask if there was
a sugar thing because every time i hear
about parents being strict like
sugar is a big part of that so we
couldn't have cereal that had more than
seven grams of sugar
so what could you have uh [ __ ] tree
bark just dirt just nothing
i mean like realistically if you go to
the middle yeah
like unsweetened almond milk and you're
at your capacity
but if you go to the grill forgot about
the milk or sugar yeah
exactly but you go to the cereal and you
look at what they got
i mean what is it it can't be any of it
you might be cheerios regular cheerios
regular cheerios probably honey nut i
think just beat the bar
if i had like you know like decent
grades or something might get some some
honey you get some [ __ ] frankenberry
it's like cocaine for your ass
oh yeah well that's bouncing off the
walls at your friend's house yeah so
when i would go to my friend's house
they would have the good [ __ ] like
cinnamon toast crunch or
fruit loops or just get [ __ ] wild
with reese's puffs and then i would just
be fiending
i'd be like miss etzel let me get
another [ __ ] bowl you know
and she's like it's 4am i'm like [ __ ] i
don't care pour up
i haven't had sugar in nine days all
right
so it made me appreciate that more um
let's see that was that was the the
biggest one i could remember
um were you a a religious family growing
up were you a church-goers
uh group jewish actually okay so on top
of the ginger jesus did you go to temple
whenever i did yeah
my mom pushed it on me pretty hard and
had a bar mitzvah everything you know uh
so looking back on it there's like a lot
of
dad's not jewish or yeah it's dez is not
jewish this is what i've learned about
i didn't know i i know you're not jewish
unless your mom's jewish yeah but which
is wild because it is right like what
the [ __ ] does the dad's
uh judaism just gets discredited exactly
and also
i want to just have a sit down with my
dad and be like what was it why
how why'd you switch over was it that
good was the [ __ ] bad that good you
know
to switch from christianity to judaism
like that yeah
and my mom said there's like maybe like
an hour's worth of hesitation
like hey you gotta switch and he's like
all right mowed the lawn game bags like
[ __ ] it we'll do it you know so
there's gotta be some better incentives
in there for that but um so i grew up
jewish my mom kind of pushed it on me
hard i
i think she just that's how she was
raised so she didn't want it to like
fall through the cracks and
she wanted to uh you know be the good
mother she's a great mom also too
but i think she just wanted to uphold
that standard and it kind of just got
pushed on me too hard to where i was
like i'm good like
if i would have found that my own way
probably but it was just too
too much pressure on me for that and i
didn't have enough [ __ ] sugar to get
through torah school that [ __ ] was so
goddamn tiring you just
yeah is that nights after like regular
it was like mondays from like
three to like 6 30. damn so three and a
half more hours of school i know i hate
ditching yeah but it wasn't even like
school did you just like watch like
[ __ ] adam sandler taste oh really it
was like
you just did a bunch of like random
aftercare we call that aftercare exactly
with yarmulkes yeah yeah that a little
bit a couple shots of some grape welch's
shooters but
other than that it was it was no
different than just like a [ __ ]
daycare but
when you're watching so you roll into
school the jewish kid with red hair
on and everyone just starts going and it
was oddly pale
well that makes sense with the red hair
yeah kind of hand-in-hand so it's just
kind of like you look back on it and
you're like oh that makes sense why
you know i had a personality built up
you know i was just getting
hit on all these different angles it's
like okay ginger jewish white kid
dad has a hybrid for the car like
there's not a lot of there's not a lot
of alpha
pumping out of the walls family that's
what i'm trying to say you know
you see me and you're like all right
this is it's almost like too easy
it's like pick a lane you want to talk
[ __ ] on i got it you know
but i like that so because i hung out
with a lot of the older kids growing up
but i was like the young kid
in the older group so like they would
talk [ __ ] to me
but if somebody else talks [ __ ] to me
they'll like get my back you know so
why were you accepted because you could
talk back
yeah i don't think i minded it i it like
it didn't like i wasn't like trying to
fight back what they're saying
i was like yeah for sure i i am that's
who i
am you know so um but also i
yeah i think i just never really was
like phased by like the feelings
of it you know which is great to be in
comedy because you kind of
need to go numb to some of these
feelings at some point yeah no
doubt you gotta yeah push them down that
real healthy [ __ ]
yeah that's what i do numb them all out
that's what i do yeah i just go
we're good all right you go to therapy
or do any therapy uh this is
year i've been one i've like put that on
like a priority list to like
deal with um i have not done it deal
with going yeah
but like i i i'm in therapy for trying
to go to therapy i literally
i just don't know how to i mean i'm sure
it's as simple as you know just finding
out if my insurance takes it but i just
i called kaiser permanente once it was
one machine to another machine i was
like all right
this is the reason i need therapy
because i can't [ __ ] talk to somebody
right now so what do you want to go
about
i just want to it's hard because like my
insecurities
are i don't well i don't know this is
just what i might think is
something they might not have the answer
to because my career is heavily based on
like
perception of the internet how they view
me so if it's like if my views are down
or
videos aren't hitting like they used to
i can't go to a therapist and be like
why is my tick tock only getting 500 000
likes when
you know and then they're just like i
don't know what are these words you're
saying to me they're like how's your
relationship at home i'm like [ __ ] home
okay why am i only getting 2 000
retweets you know
so i it's like i need like a millennial
therapist that's just like hey views
don't matter you're you're making a
career out of something you love just do
that and i'd be like
oh okay so i'm just trying to like
so that's that's where the question is
what is it about that approval you need
did you not get approval growing up were
you was your dad always busy mom always
working where you just never do a latch
key kid
what does that mean that means come home
from school by yourself let yourself in
yeah and then your parents come home a
few hours later from work
yes that was me your latchkey kid i
think i was just also there's no
direction for me like if if i had an
older brother who did this career out
i'd be like oh i can
reach out to him or i can talk to him
but you know i have people in this
community of comedy that like i can
reach out to him like hey
do you ever experience this or you ever
have that going on but
i never grew up like i feel like i'm
kind of on my own team here
so i don't really know who to talk to
about some of these like insecurities
and type things and
i have a girlfriend i'll talk to her
i'll be like something she goes well
you're only doing your best and i'm like
i get that but like i need an answer
down
deep down that's like well here's why
this video didn't do well you know
so is it really about the videos or is
it more about
the approval of that i think the
approval because the [ __ ] up part is
like
every video i make at some point i like
like making it you know whether it's the
writing or the editing or
the filming of 10 000 videos one of them
mathematically is gonna perform the
least exactly
yeah something's going to be viewed the
least right yeah
i think about like baseball each video
is a pitch and it's like okay we [ __ ]
knocking this out of the park
or is this a foul ball into the [ __ ]
hot dog stance so
you gotta like and i just the weird part
problem is like i'm i can't practice
what i preach like somebody will come to
me
with video advice and then i'll be like
well you know man just the next one's
that much better than my [ __ ] like flops
and i'm like well what the [ __ ]
happening with me
so i kind of just uh yeah i don't know
i but then again i've never been to a
therapist so i don't know
i think they get the root of that
instead of being like well let's talk
about snapchat they'll be like well you
feel insecure
because x y and z and then like yeah
they're really going to dive into some
[ __ ]
yeah yeah [ __ ] we're here do you go to
therapy i i have a bunch
yeah i'm not right now but i'll be going
back soon again yeah
and i've tried different kinds of things
i mean so many therapists it's
it's dating it's like dating yeah that's
what i've heard it's like you interview
with a bunch of them you see who you
connect with
and uh yeah my girlfriend was going on
for a couple weeks and then
this they like said something about her
and then they had like beef and then
there's like 30 minutes left of the
of the you know of the appointment it's
like who's paying for this
it's like you just told me to leave yeah
there's 30 minutes left on the table
therapy's not cheap so
the therapist said leave well they were
just like i don't think we're gonna see
eye to eye on this and then she was like
okay fine
and then they like had a little weird
standoff
man i had a therapist one time session
one i sit down he starts eating while
he's talking to me like a sandwich and
[ __ ] and i'm like
what are you doing he's like yeah i'm
just having my dinner i go in my session
i go no yeah you can't be thinking about
problems in a salisbury state
yeah i said i need a therapist that's
gonna [ __ ]
give me their time and attention
undivided attention and then i
i went back again and that dude wouldn't
ended up being a great therapist
he was like he's like i just called him
out sometimes just got to [ __ ] tell
him like what are you doing
i'm in here right now my life is falling
apart and you're over there having
a turkey and [ __ ] cheese like you
wait 50 minutes
oh you went back to the same guy yeah
after i told him and then he was
dude i'm so glad i did he was great had
an incredible memory
he remembered he'd like and this is your
blue moment i'm like yeah
[ __ ] yeah he just didn't remember when
the [ __ ] to eat he couldn't remember
what he did
exactly like could you just wait
yeah i mean if you want to wolf it down
i'll sit outside for another [ __ ]
five minutes
i gotta go to the bathroom then just jam
it down stomach [ __ ] ground the whole
time i'm crying
over here right that's funny you're just
sobbing up your tears with some rye
bread i got you real quick
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor policy genius
now april means a lot of not so fun
things right it means getting fooled
you're getting rained on and you're
getting your taxes done so
if you need a positive experience to
balance it all out consider shopping for
your home
and auto insurance with policy genius
policy genius
can help you find home and auto coverage
similar to what you have now
but at a lower price all right here's
what you got to do first you're going to
head to policygenius.com
you're going to answer a few quick
questions about yourself and your
property
then policy genius takes it from there
they'll compare rates
from america's top insurers from
progressive to allstate to find your
lowest quotes i just did this i just
went through
and did all of this from the coverages
to everything going on
policy genius is great the policy genius
team will look at all the ways to
maximize your savings including
bundling your home and auto policies if
policy genius finds a better rate than
what you're paying now
they'll switch you over for free that
kind of service is earned policy genius
a five-star rating across over thousands
of reviews on trustpilot
and google policy genius can promise
that you won't leave their website
feeling like a fool they save customers
up to one thousand fifty five dollars
per
year compared to their current home and
auto policies
head to policygenius.com to get started
right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
our next sponsor is coors pure do you
ever feel like living
a healthy lifestyle is hard like you try
so damn hard to keep
up with what's considered healthy you
know you push yourself
each day getting better and better but
it's absolutely overwhelming well
living a healthy lifestyle is important
but it should not stop your enjoyment
that's when you reach
for coors pure since it's all organic
and has zero sugar
you can enjoy it without feeling guilty
look when i drink beers i like light
beers coors light
has always been a favorite of mine but
core sent me some of this stuff and i'm
telling you
it's it's it's a great beer
it's coors pure it's organic but it's
chill about it all right
new coors pure is a refreshingly simple
beer with organic barley
organic hops and water i know you're
wondering how many calories it's 92
calories and there are zero grams of
sugar to answer your next question
it is the perfect beer to celebrate the
wins of
everyday life coors pure is all about
promoting balance and giving aggressive
affirmations to everyday heroes so
whether you got that run in or hell if
you just got
you know your running clothes on coors
pure celebrates you
coors pure is the perfect beer to
celebrate the winds of everyday life
so when you want to enjoy a beer without
the guilt reach for coors pure it's
organic but chill about it
go to coorspure.com to see where you can
find
coors pure celebrate responsibly coors
brewing company
albany georgia so what made you want to
move to la then was it comedy is that
what you came down
for yeah yeah how old were you when you
left home
uh so i went to college when i was 18.
and then
where your sister was going or had gone
no she she was in like
central california i went up north to
san jose okay so i was
at san jose state and then i had done a
little bit of stand-up before college
and then my like did you do the improv
up there yeah yeah so
that's a beautiful thing it's great it's
like it's literally like a theater it's
like
they said houdini used to perform there
in the day it's like magical
i mean i lowkey got spoiled because that
was like maybe the fifth show i ever did
was a bringer at
the san jose improv yeah because when i
was at san jose i was doing a little bit
of stand up my like
junior year that's when i was like all
right i gotta get back into this i just
did two years of [ __ ]
being an idiot and a friend just
drowning my brain cells with four lokos
and then after that i was like i gotta
like
okay what do i really want to do after
college so my junior year i was doing
some stand-up
and during one of the open mics outside
of the school i met some guy and
i told him i was in a fraternity i was
like yeah i could probably bring out
like 30 or 40 people and again and the
guy goes
what do you say because for a [ __ ]
bringer producer
he's like i'll give you a [ __ ] three
hours if you want i was like no all i
got is
you're going last yeah yeah everybody's
staying through yourself
right so um and all these guys in the
fret were like we have nothing better to
do
and and they're like frat guys here like
two drink minimum they're like
[ __ ] i hope yeah i'm gonna do a 38
drink minimum you're like all right well
you're an alcoholic corbin so let's
slow it down so they were just pumped
because they got to drink on a weekday
the bringing shows were always on
wednesday thursday or like sunday
so i was getting thrown up and i was
doing these like
these some of these shows and i was i
was i had no right being there and i was
and i was with guys who are still
running the circuit now who were like
they're probably looking at me like why
am i on the [ __ ] lineup with this
little kid
but i was able to do that and i started
making videos on like vine if you
remember that
yeah of course making vine videos and
then i was just doing stand-up my junior
year that's like all i did junior year
was was that and then
uh my senior year i was doing both of
those
vine kind of like you know died out a
little bit so i was just all stand up
i'll stand up move down here right after
like two weeks after college and then i
had an internship
at uh the groundlings on melrose yeah of
course i went there for years
yeah i went through their uh writing lab
like level three oh [ __ ] that's like
that that's
[ __ ] that's great i just didn't have
any interest in trying to be a
groundling
you know and i knew how competitive and
how also
like you know they would be like look
will ferrell's still growling like
people needed to leave
oh yeah spaces to open up for the sunday
company to slide up as well
the way it was explained to me yeah and
it makes sense now looking back on in
hindsight
and uh i was also an intern there so i
knew all like the background stuff and
they're like hey the process start to
finish can take anywhere from like
four to like eight years and i was like
that's a [ __ ] lot of time
especially like a digital era and like
you know everything else you can do to
like try to
get in front of a camera or in front of
the right people so i was doing that but
um
yeah i thought the internship was going
to be like literally it came out with
christian wig and
will ferrell they're like no just go
[ __ ] reorganize
posters in the attic i was like sweating
yeah they treat me like
just like just [ __ ] they're like go do
that get it did it
i was just everybody's [ __ ] there and
then i did that for like six months and
they're like you know what we like you
we'll give you thursday night shifts
paid and it was like 32 dollars i was
like
and what did you do like tickets or
something yeah box office
yeah or i'd run the concession stand and
get free recess out of it so
that's what i'm talking about yeah i did
that that was like 2015 to like 2016-ish
and then uh
i was working for a company called all
deaf digital they're uh russell simmons
yeah did it yeah and that was cool
because it was music and comedy
so i was kind of in that space and uh
they'd shot a lot like sketch comedy so
they like put me in stuff here and there
and then kind of just like work my way
up to be like i guess even like a cast
member for them
so and then while doing that i was just
doing stand-up and also making videos at
the same time and where are you living
and stuff at the time so
are you getting by and yeah so i was
living in studio city
and in a pool house so somebody's pool
house
yeah and it was just a room there was no
like there was like a little ac unit but
there was no where to cook there's no
wi-fi
the funniest thing is since there was no
wi-fi i knew the people that lived in
the house
so if i wanted to like watch some
[ __ ] porn get get crazy in the pool
house i'd have to go inside
load up like a few videos yeah and then
like not close my laptop for anything
so i'd have to have it all loaded up and
plus they're in the house i gotta
pretend
i'm just doing work you know just
[ __ ] sitting in the corner just
looking at pornhub.com
and then i would just go off into the
the little uh pool house
and heaven forbid i click refresh i'm
[ __ ] so it'd be
it was really funny and i liked it
because it was a pool house i had an air
mattress and i slept on it for like
eight months
and um i mean i i just
i liked it because i never wanted to be
home because there was nothing to do
there
and in the valley there's so many open
mics so i'd be doing like flappers that
were not bigger like the oyster house or
the oyster bar whatever it's called
i would just be like trying to hit all
these different places and i was like
never really home
and then uh the first year i was here
was all stand up and i was like all
right let's get back from the video
video hype and then just like try to do
one video a week and
just kept going from there and then
after like a year on some change i
finally had one video do do some numbers
and i was like cool
let's like not let the light die out and
just keep running with it
so we have a little list over here of
some things we talked about tell me
about you said you had uh
a near-death experience i want to hear
about it yeah so
as soon as i started like smoking early
on i was kind of in that like
smoking drinking early on like freshman
year of high school just kind of like
that's what we did on the weekends you
know and your parents ever find out that
they know
yeah they found out but like i don't i
don't know i
i think a lot of it was like a don't ask
don't tell type thing because the same
week they found weed under my bed
i found weed in my dad's room so
it's one of those like you don't say
anything i don't say anything is that
mine
yeah yeah so and i think he knew that i
found
his weed because like i think i either
like took a nug or like it was moved
enough for him to be like
oh [ __ ] somebody's onto me so uh they
found it and i was like oh i
found that weed somewhere in on a hiking
trail even though the bag was like so
clean no dirt on it
just like a perfect zip lock um so
yeah i i never they were like aware of
it they caught me drinking the summer
going into
uh ninth grade so i got in trouble for
that i don't remember what happened but
uh
yeah so that's just what i was around
and then one night this girl
holly was having a party and she was
like her like
parents owned a mcdonald's or some [ __ ]
damn like
one of them in town but when you're in a
small town of 60
000 people like you [ __ ] you know who
owns that goddamn mcdonald's yeah
and he had like he had uh the mcdonald's
dollars the mcbucks
and people would get drunk and steal him
from his house man people used to give
us
i used to love that there was always one
house in the neighborhood of halloween
it would throw those into yeah
it's [ __ ] great yeah you're like i
don't need a goddamn dollars at
mcdonald's
you take this over your goddamn candy
corn exactly i don't need 100 grand bars
you give me [ __ ] 100
bucks right now those things but like
yeah since he owned that people would we
she had like a party house and she
coincidentally also had a pool house
this is just a [ __ ] pool house
podcast
um that we would party in there
and uh we were skateboarding back home
to another friend's house
was like a mile away and she lived in
like this like windy hill
and i could skate but not like well like
i couldn't do tricks and [ __ ] but i
could like hang with the group
turns out when you're hammered no can do
you know
and i just remember going down this hill
and it goes and it makes like this like
kind of like slow like kind of like a
nascar
type turn and then it was a straight
away and then another sharp left
and i make the first turn i remember i
had you hauling ass pulling ass yeah
no helmet obviously no nothing no helmet
half a brain
how much have you drank at this point
god uh
enough to
jesus i i mean i have no idea i don't
have a zero concept of like what time it
is
you know what you drank probably
something stupid i used to drink
things in high school called mad dogs 20
20.
yeah i mean they look amazing yeah they
taste like they taste like [ __ ]
the marketing is so i mean the label
doesn't even look good the label
looks like something you'd find on a
vintage t-shirt you know it's just like
a little crest md 2020
but the colors of it you're like i need
that in my body those were just
[ __ ] four lokas without the
carbonation i feel like so
i i was probably drinking one of those
because they were like two dollars
they're cheap
and i just remember leaving i was in the
back of the group
and then the last thing i remember is
this is straight away how many people
are in this group skating right now
probably five or six okay yeah they're
all just hauling ass pulling ass
time too night time oh yeah probably two
or three in the morning but the other
group i was hanging out with that night
they were like oh like all they did was
skate all they did was go to skate park
that's like
so they could skate whether they were in
a coma or not like they could [ __ ]
still figure it out me on the other hand
i could barely skate like
sober but i could like hang a little bit
and in my head i just remember seeing it
straight away and i'm like
i remember where like i don't know if
you've ever been drunk and you've ever
been hit
your brain goes you don't feel it you
just go oh i got hit like your brain
registered i've been sober and been hit
i've been hit a lot yeah your brain's
like hang on
yeah we just got it exactly so i
remember seeing this pole my brain goes
you need to make a left and then i go
yup
and i just don't make the sharp left and
then i just probably go on i don't need
maybe like a golf cart speed like a good
golf cart down like a
yeah and uh yeah straight into it
straight into a total
telephone telephone pole yeah and what
happened got a concussion
so i didn't break your [ __ ] face
nothing was broken i don't know what
happened like
drunk that's why if you would have
tensed up you probably would have broke
every bone in your body
that's a great point because if i was
sober i probably would have tried to
block it with my that's what i mean if
you were sober you would attack like do
something like [ __ ] man-made shield
but i think i literally like
you know in cartoons when a body wraps
around like something like the arm scars
and legs yeah yeah yeah some like tweety
bird [ __ ] so
i think it was something along those
lines where i just like
i just remember the split second before
i hit it and then i woke up on this
guy's couch
for real yeah damn you didn't go to the
hospital or anything
no no no because we were all like 16.
wonder how they got your knocked ass i
wanted they just laid you on the board
and skated you
that way i think one of the guys who was
at the party at the time
who knows from what i was told one of
the guys at the party
was like he just got his license and he
was still at the party
so i think he drove me back to the
friend's house and was like
just keep him and this is before like
phones had the internet
so they're all just like what do we do
put [ __ ] uh frozen corn on his
forehead like i just woke up and
everybody's just staring at me on the
couch
and i like had zero grasp of what
happened i was like what's going on like
why is everybody looking at me like when
did we leave like
it's really weird and then the next day
i just went back up
to my parents house like nothing
happened and
they never found out no unless they
listen what made
how'd they find that weed what made them
go looking
probably just the people i was hanging
out with were people that looked like
they'd smoke
and i didn't hide it in a like a hard
spot just literally under the mattress
and it was like lighter weed clear eyes
like it couldn't have been more like
a starter kit exactly yeah
yeah under the mattress is like you
might as well just put on your [ __ ]
desk at that point it's like oh where's
where's his weed boom you know it's so
yeah i remember uh that that was
probably the closest i think
i've had to like a near-death incident
because i mean who knows if there was
like
had like a rock hit before and we're
going straight into the poll i mean i
don't really know i i i'm
so thankful that i walked away from that
just being like
you know just kind of shook it off the
next day i was like [ __ ] yeah let's go
get those mcdonald's bucks back
yeah yeah yeah body leaks yeah with the
egg mcmuffin
well i asked you too about uh therapy
and stuff and you said you have
you said you have inner demons at night
time
yeah what what did happen do you still
smoke with you by the way
sometimes you do it you don't smoke to
go to sleep or anything like that no
no no no what's going on at night for
you i think it's just
the the everything slows down what i
like in the day is like my brain doesn't
have
time to think about anxiety because
you're doing other [ __ ] yeah you're
doing other [ __ ] you're staying busy
you're getting texts you're getting
calls you're doing [ __ ] but at night
there's something about
just like nobody's hitting you up at
like
you know 1am you're you're it's just
you're by yourself and then like the
the city's madness kind of like mellows
out it's just you with your thoughts
that's like whenever i have to go to
sleep early for a flight i never can
i'm just laying there and i just that's
when the thoughts start creeping in
where do you go with your thoughts what
thoughts creep in what are your regular
thoughts of anxiety
the biggest anxiety is uh
what like what am i doing with my life
what what what is the meaning of all
this where am i going with all this it's
like i have the
this like this career in the video world
and uh
but you know what is my like five ter my
five year goal it's like do i want to be
you know 53 years old i'm like what's up
guys
swipe on up to the new but in reality
but in the reality of it is like five
years away from it but the reality of it
is
that is that is the future like i
shouldn't be ashamed of that yeah you
know instead of me being like
i want to you know work on a cbs show or
whatever i think that's where my brain
was growing up as a kid be like
okay do interviews there's shows i'm
like i want to get on letterman this
show and even on anything
you know i mean you have these dreams of
[ __ ] you want to do and it's like yeah
it shows nice
carson well yeah right all right exactly
give me a comic view
so um i don't know i think it's just
the the biggest fear for somebody i
think at least in my position
mentally for me is like the relevancy
factor of just being like
of just having what i have now and then
either blowing it or just like
it fizzles out you know you you know
there's a trajectory of
a lot of stuff and it's like okay let's
say i'm up here and [ __ ] starts to you
know go slow down
not losing my mind and being like okay
how do i dig myself out of this and have
a comeback which you know a lot of
people do
and just not letting uh i think it's
just a lot of the views and all the [ __ ]
just there's so much going on it's like
the [ __ ] dow jones in my head but
goddamn instagram
video views and all that [ __ ] so it's
kind of just like though
you know what am i doing where do i want
to go with this it's just kind of like
so many questions at once but what do
you do to calm yourself
that's not good i just [ __ ] go on my
phone and be like cool look at
[ __ ] ass on instagram zoom in you
know it's like
dude it's not great whenever i get
anxiety i i literally i'll just like
roll over in bed and i'll just like open
in the app and then be like cool drown
it out or like go on twitter and just
like
and just push it down and block it out
yeah and that's just
what you're trying to learn how to deal
with exactly that's the type of [ __ ]
yeah therapy so i don't get those
thoughts too often
mainly if i'm hungover oh they're
[ __ ] coming in hot
really is it something with alcohol that
does that i think it's just like i feel
present also
yeah that and i think i'm also lazier
when i'm hungover which uh didn't know
if he knew that i was going to say it
if you know your mind is out there
[ __ ] just you know i feel like [ __ ]
yeah well when i [ __ ] hit a goddamn
telephone pole the next day i was but
i think i ran i think as a human you get
like 250 get out of jail free passes for
hangovers
yeah and i use them [ __ ] up quick i
was like 19 getting hangovers so
um yeah i don't know what it is but like
whenever i'm hungover everybody's
productive you know i open up
my [ __ ] phone people are booking [ __ ]
people are like just [ __ ] landed this
netflix series and i'm just laying there
just
just with like nacho cheese coming out
of my ears and i'm like what am i doing
right now
it's the hard it's hard to keep those
blinders on and stay in your [ __ ]
lane and focus on your [ __ ]
not look left and right worry about
that's a great point it's hard it's
really hard not to do that because
naturally you're competitive also and
you're like
how [ __ ] did he get that yeah 100 we're
auditioning for that
right exactly exactly so it's kind of
like yeah keeping the blinders on and
whatnot but um
but also i've learned from therapy
especially this um
emdr therapy is uh about future tripping
she called it
and it's just don't worry about the
future you're worrying about these
everything tomorrow next day and then
and then and then
none of it is happening and you're just
spiraling inside worrying about some
[ __ ] that's not gonna happen when
reality
you're probably laying there in a
comfortable [ __ ] bed with a roof over
your head yeah belly full of food and
you know yeah and that's something uh
and people who love you
yeah there it is and and i try to uh you
know remember those
moments whenever i feel like that or
easier said than done bro you're gonna
be crying a lot exactly
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah but there's
there's times where it's just like i'm
like okay but it feels so weird it feels
so robotic to look out and be like i am
thankful for this
you know i'm just looking out at you
know [ __ ] studio city be like
here we are and and in my neighbors
exactly yeah so uh but it is good to
remind yourself about those things but
like
what always helps me and i'm not like a
buff guy by any means so i don't know if
you could [ __ ]
tell but you're kind of jacked yeah kind
of but like whenever like just getting
out of the house or working out or doing
something
always like takes me out of that slop
yeah the sun always makes you feel
better
me too but also just getting outside i
don't know what it is about
hiking or just walking it clears my mind
but then i become like this open
channel of ideas especially when i
listen to music i put
i put scenes to music in my head that i
think would be funny when i hear a song
i'm big on the words but also i like to
put like what i think will be a really
funny scene to that song and i try to
pair them up to
songs you would never yeah you know like
bad to the bone i don't i'm not gonna
put some biker
you know what i mean it was gonna be
that it would be something different
completely different that you wouldn't
you know see it's a good idea but um
you know the whole future trip anything
it's hard not to do that it's hard not
to worry about
where your next paycheck is coming from
or next
meal so true it's it's in the future why
even
because you have no control over it
doesn't matter you lay there and think
if i do this this is going to happen and
then the [ __ ] universe is going to do
some whatever the [ __ ] it wants to do
like i did not even see i didn't even
think of that [ __ ] example exactly
didn't even cross my mind
any success i've gotten in this career
came from a place that i wouldn't have
guessed it you know like what it where
i'm just saying like um like you
wouldn't have thought youtube
or instagram i mean i've always wanted
to do that but like the way i got
or like maybe the video i thought that
was going to put me up there did the
biggest like
one video that did like crazy things for
me was like this white claw video
and i made that and just kind of posted
it as like a all right whatever you know
like
zero attachment to it zero like this is
the one i was like
if it works it works like and that's
probably why it worked because you had
that attitude
exactly so or that or like how i met my
manager was like never the way i would
i would have thought i had to like
audition and do all this crazy stuff but
like my manager was just a fan who
signed
another guy and then it's just like all
like everything of success like
i would have never been like oh i'm
gonna get um
on comedy central because i tag my post
every day
um but just however it happens you know
the less i worried about
how i'm gonna get it instead of working
towards the thing
it kind of just found its way there so
instead of like
freaking out about the future and
setting a goal specifically in the
future and wondering how i'm going to
get the goal it's kind of just like all
right let's just work towards that goal
and
it'll take itself that's it it's going
to do what it wants to do so just
work toward the goal and it's going to
[ __ ] happen let's take a quick break
and tell you about our next sponsor
skillshare skillshare is an
online learning community that offers
membership with me you guys have heard
me talk about skillshare a lot
uh there's a ton to explore there's real
projects to create and the support
of your fellow creative skillshare
empowers you
to accomplish real growth all right i
wanted to do some uh
cooking classes with my daughter i tell
you about it and uh we went on we
we did this um program called kids
kitchen cooking from scratch
with kids under five right my daughter's
a picky eater
so i wanted to show her that hey here
are the five six things you love
going into this thing but now it's a
tortilla or it's a sandwich
stuff like that but we're learning how
to cook see what goes in your food
what goes in your body and practice
makes progress
advancing toward a goal is achievable
with short lessons
and hands-on projects and there's
nothing better
than getting better all right
accomplishing growth is extremely
satisfying so do something today you
couldn't do yesterday with classes
designed
for real life skillshare is also
incredibly affordable especially when
compared
to pricey in-person classes and
workshops an annual subscription
is less than 10 bucks a month all right
explore your creativity at
skillshare.com
honeydew and get a free trial of premium
membership
again it's a free trial premium
membership at skillshare
honeydew our next sponsor is expressvpn
you know what's not fair
the fact that netflix hides thousands of
shows and movies from you based on your
location
and then has the nerve to increase their
prices on you that's right they've just
raised their prices
once again now you could just cancel
your subscription in protest
or you could be smart about it and make
sure you're getting your full money's
worth
by using expressvpn like i do so you
might not
know that what's on your netflix in your
country is completely different from
what someone in the uk or japan
has on theirs using expressvpn i can
control which country i want netflix
to think i'm in i was just on vacation
in mexico i'm down there i'm using
expressvpn to make it think i'm in the
states
so while i'm in mexico i'm watching all
the shows i love hearing the states
expressvpn is also super fast and it
works on your phone
your laptop even your smart tvs so you
can watch your shows on the big screen
with
zero buffering okay so be smart stop
paying
full price for streaming services and
only getting access to a fraction of
their content
get your money's worth at expressvpn.com
honeydew do not forget to use my link so
you can get three
extra months for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash honeydew expressvpn
dot com slash honeydew to learn more
now let's get back to the duke yeah i
mean but yeah like you're saying earlier
it's easier said than done
way easier how old are you 20 28. so
what's been the biggest disappointment
for you so far
personally the fact probably the fact
that i'm going to ask professionally
next but personally what's been the
biggest disappointment
i think it's getting things i wanted so
bad
when i was like 17 or 18 for starting
comedy
getting those things and not feeling
like on top of the world
it's like certain things in my head i'd
be like why don't i feel happier
so it's like i don't know
some of this [ __ ] just doesn't like for
me the biggest thing i did was was
gramercy theater in new york
damn you got to do that yeah wow so i
did that for the new york comedy
festival
last year and i was like i should be
happier
why am i not sold it out why am i not
like
you know and then i've talked to other
people like yeah i feel the same way it
just means you're on the right track
and you're like not getting caught up
and like sucking your own dick
yeah that's really what it is because
you get this moment
it's an it's a weird business you get
this [ __ ] high
and then it's over and literally
tomorrow is
now what yeah it's it's that fast
i don't care if it's a four-hour [ __ ]
special netflix is giving you
it's over the next day yeah and then you
can ride off of that for a little bit
but still you're like okay
what's next though what's next yeah so i
think it's just that
but well once you can understand that
that it's like okay i didn't get super
stoked about it because that was kind of
in my plan the whole time
then you're like oh that makes sense but
i think that was just the first thing
where i was like
should i be happier should i take a
moment to like reflect
you know but i i do think about times of
like where it started out
to them be that's where i feel gratitude
is comparing where i started out
and like thinking about isa the same guy
that owns the ventura harbor comic club
used to run out for murray calendars do
you ever do that one which one up in
valencia jr is coming no
never did that one i used to host it
every friday and saturday and marie
calendars
i did it well marie counters used to
have one here on wilshire they have one
upstairs it's actually called
calendars they would love to correct you
when you go in there there
they're like the smart ship right and
then it spun off to marie counters but
they're
like the first restaurant yeah but they
had upstairs
back in the day and it was comedy there
on like a wednesday night and [ __ ] yeah
yeah this was up in uh valencia by six
flags
and i hosted every friday and saturday
when i first moved out here because it
was like 10 minutes each night
it paid decent because it was one of
those where you like you tick their
tickets
you checked everybody in and then when
you're finished you go on stage like hey
i'm also the guy doing comedy and nobody
gives a [ __ ]
so yeah like and and that was
the audience of that like the average
age was probably just
[ __ ] obituary it was just it was all
old
so thinking back and being like okay
gram receives all people who are like my
age who love me
versus marie calendars and these people
could couldn't give less of a [ __ ] about
me
you know they're just like cool and we
used to get paid in pies
there no swear to god
so many people a lot of people would and
run through that i mean
guys like eric myers and craig conan are
all guys that i would like
see it that marie calendars and like
it's cool
and i caught up with craig on his
podcast recently we were talking about
like
you know those little things so that's
when i feel the most gratitude sometimes
not in the moment but when i like
take a step back and be like oh [ __ ] you
just get paid in pies to get
heckled by a guy with no teeth that's
right so paid in pies
drink tickets yeah all that [ __ ]
until you get somewhere so what's been
your biggest
um disappointment professionally so far
damn uh i mean did you panic when vine
went away
was that oh it was that a revenue stream
it wasn't yet
yeah no i wasn't really big on there but
i was just making videos on there i had
a few things that did okay
but it was enough to spark the engine of
my head big okay you
this is how it works you know you can
make some videos and they can take its
course but
the biggest disappointment um [ __ ]
uh i've talked about this before on
other podcasts but with that white claw
video that came out
i made a shirt with a quote from it and
then i put it on their logo but altered
it a little bit
and i did it without running past any
legal team this is before i had any
manager
or any agent i had a manager but i
didn't have like a lawyer or anybody
like an extensive end
and i put the shirts up for sale and
ended up selling like a couple thousand
in two days
a couple thousand t-shirts and uh they
hit me with a cease and assist
too did they ask you for the money or
just told you to stop
so where where they kind of pinpointed
me
what is that white clothes dude they
[ __ ] they they
hit me with like every different angle
they're like if you do this we'll get
you there if you do this we'll get you
there
so it was a print on demand service so
they were collecting orders
so the sale was for like a week and then
it was going to go to the print shop and
they're like hey look we know you
haven't printed any of these yet
had you printed them and then sold them
we tell you to just stop but since they
haven't even been to production yet oh
so you could have got at least a couple
bucks out of this [ __ ] thing
more than a couple dollars oh yeah i
could have got a [ __ ] [ __ ] c
so special out of this [ __ ] you know
this [ __ ] was
it was like good money and and i was
[ __ ] stopped because it hadn't
printed yet yeah
and they're like look we know you have a
day left so a day and some change left
so it hasn't even gone to the printer
yet
so if you print them that's when our
legal team will fully come after you
because then you went against the cease
and desist
so i had to return all the shirts and i
mean the messages i was getting were
just
everybody's a [ __ ] law critic now
you're [ __ ] trying to three years
right 25 year old right comedian
everyone knows everything
i don't [ __ ] know what the [ __ ] to do
you think i'm gonna go to court i don't
know
uh the case for trevor wallace versus
white club
yes so that was i l
so for the terms of like the shirt went
up wednesday i got the season assist
like tuesday
and then everything was back to normal
wednesday but it was like
the wildest 72 hours in and when
and this is the first time i ever saw
like money money and i was
[ __ ] living like it i was googling
how to buy a used m3
like i was [ __ ] used that's where my
bar is not even like
a lot of you like 20 20. i'm talking use
them
because my jew brain is like how do i
get a nice car but like
asterisk next to nice you know and i was
ordering [ __ ]
postmates with like matcha lemonade i
don't even like lemonade i'm just
ordering like an [ __ ] because i can
because i thought
that night i was like i just hit it big
with this t-shirt
and then the next morning they're like
we're actually gonna need that money
back
and uh yeah that was a i've learned
more in that than i ever learned in all
of my years of schooling but
i mean the chances that that shirt like
took off like that i had zero idea i
thought
i thought i'd sell a couple handfuls but
like i just posted a shirt everywhere
and
people shared it like the shirt was like
a meme and i was like
oh [ __ ] we're onto something here so
yeah that was i don't even know that was
just that was a disappointment that was
a mistake it was
uh everything in one but that [ __ ]
wolf
i still have night terrors about that
that's where my anxiety comes from
absolutely yeah wake up in the middle of
night and yell white claws and punch my
window out yeah
well especially when you have an income
the way ours you know if youtube decides
they want to demonetize a [ __ ]
there it goes yeah there's no arguing it
there's
just like no we just we're going to shut
your page yeah
and that's like wait that's my job not
anymore exactly
so that's kind of where like and that's
a whole thinking in the future
there is times where i'm like what if
youtube just went away
what is my job what's my income but it's
like when i quit my job i had that same
thought
and then after a while i stopped
thinking about it and then it took care
of itself
when you quit what job when i was
working at all deaf digital oh that was
the
quit there yeah so i quit there in 2017
2017 and uh i was there for
those 2018 i was there for three years
and then i was just kind of like how am
i gonna make money i don't know i'll
figure it out but when i stopped
worrying about how i'm gonna make money
is when i started to make money which i
think that makes sense in the long run
it's like
if you worry about something it's not
gonna get done but if you kind of just
do the thing
without worrying it'll get you to take
care of itself yeah we'll get you to the
finish line
so what do you what's another thing you
want to do you're going to stick with
stand up when it comes back
yeah i like what i'm doing now i just uh
i want to add different elements to it
just kind of level it up a little bit
and uh you know i i think for stand-up
it's one of those things where it's like
you know we were talking about earlier
how uh groundlings is still like will
ferrell is still like up here that's how
it is with stand-up especially now more
than ever so it's like
somebody shows around town it's like
you're going up with the big dogs so
it's like i want to
still be able to like stay sharp because
going up in front of my own audience is
one thing because they love me you know
they're there for you but it's like
if i'm just at a random [ __ ] show in
the in the belly room and it's like burr
just went up and i'm like
okay obviously i'm gonna [ __ ] myself but
like how do i like like okay let's pull
a small list and let's keep that sharp
so that's something i always want to
like
be sharp on but videos i kind of just
want to like try different stuff or make
little higher production stuff
experiment a little bit
um and you know i get auditions here and
there and never book anything
but uh what do you want to do i i want
to do what i do now and what's crazy is
i told myself
early on i was like i want to stay in
town during the week
do spots at night filming the day and
then tour on the weekends
that's kind of what i do before kova and
a little bit now but
um i do want to do some stuff in like
the traditional world just to give it a
shot
you know everybody's telling me like no
[ __ ] stick in this lane and i agree
i definitely want to stay in digital and
i don't want to abandon the people that
got me here
but what do you want to try
just like longer form content whether
it's uh you know writing a show or
oh writing a show yeah writing show
being in it and okay
you know being doing the movie thing
just to just because i mean like
to to tell the you know like the younger
me like
the teenage trevor who's like i have all
these comedy dreams and goals i want to
be on tv i want to be in movies
and then i want to do it to be like okay
if i liked it sure stick with it if i
didn't like it i go hey
i did the thing you know so just uh
checking that off the list
have you ever had a regular job yeah
what was it that was working all deaf
digital i was i did all their social
media but that's also in entertainment
have you ever done anything like uh
starbucks or oh yeah yeah so i worked at
a jamba juice in college
you did yeah i'm sure you could tell by
my looks very jamba juice
yeah it was great dude a [ __ ] if i
can find a picture i'll send it to you
it's just
my college i was just a [ __ ] tool i
was in a frat i took like creatine like
buff up but like my body was just a
[ __ ] water bath i was gonna say it's
all water weight
it's all bluff it's just a ziploc bag
jammed in my arm
so i was on like creatine i'd wear the
[ __ ]
the visor jamba juice orange shirt that
didn't fit me trying to show like
two inches of bicep so i did that i also
worked
at a kiosk inside of the costco you know
i did that my senior year
that that paid decent for for a college
gig
so you know it's kiosks that everybody
doesn't make eye contact with them yeah
i did that and that was for uh
uh window covering blinds whatever yeah
yeah we just like tried to sell people
that
uh i would like a little microphone all
that [ __ ] i don't know no i didn't
do that now but we just haven't you
would kill that your character now how
are you not doing that video i don't
know
please do a [ __ ] selling blinds at
the costco
stand guy i need to but uh and then i
worked at a
a lot of just frozen blended [ __ ] in my
life i worked at a uh
a frozen yogurt store in high school for
three years and
yeah but that's not really like labor
it's not like work like anybody
listening to this like oh it's
responsibility
yeah that's responsibility true yeah and
it gave me something to do and uh
did that then i worked at my friends
like plant nursery a little bit
during some of the summers and but you
had always wanted to do comedy then yeah
so that was something you knew
even before you tried doing stand-up
like i want to do comedy
yeah i mean i didn't necessarily i
didn't know i wanted to do comedy until
i did it for the first time i was like
oh i can i can do this professionally
how do i figure that out so
gotcha uh but i always just love comedy
just growing up and just watching like
anything jim carrey anything robin
williams were like yeah i was just so
attracted to
that style of entertainment and like
anything action or drama or superheroes
never really did it for me
so yeah i just was always
even like looking back my mom found some
[ __ ] in a baby book that was like
what is your dream job in like third
grade i wrote comedian
did you yeah yeah i knew back then too i
wanted to
i mean i knew you i i i mean i thought i
wanted to do stand-up and be on snl
that's what i thought comedy was
yeah you know you do stand up you get on
snl you get in the movies that's what i
thought comedy was but and it's for time
it was
sure it was um but man has it evolved in
the last 20 years
yeah and rapidly changing more so in
like the last like three years yeah
clubhouse and all these things just
popping up and like [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's a lot where'd you start
out at um in baltimore i mean
i i i say i started out but i only did
about three or four shows
but it's where i did start before i came
here i did a
baltimore comedy factory yeah is that
the one in the hotel oh
it is now yeah that thing has moved so
many places it's finally in a [ __ ]
corner of a hotel now
yeah yeah i did that with some of the
guys at all that digital because the
guys i was working with at the time
were also in the videos but they were
also touring and doing stuff um
yeah it was a fun time i remember we
like we all pulled up in like this like
suv and
the back of this like loading dock and
they're like we're [ __ ] i mean every
comedy club to some extent you're always
walking through the kitchen going down
like fry cooks with one eye or waving at
you from going
exactly yeah yeah that was a good club
all right so i asked um we're about
there i ask
every guest who's a first time guest yes
sir
uh after everything we've talked about
now and knowing what and you
sort of did touch on a tiny bit but
going back to your 16 year old self
what would you tell 16 year old trevor
what advice would you give
to yourself i do i think i'll say this
advice but it's still something i need
to tell myself to this day is is
patience with it
and uh just like keep your eye on the
prize and what you said with like the
blinders it's like
just focus on what you want and what
however whatever work you're doing just
make sure it's in that same direction
you know so i think just patience with
it because like
quick success is not the success you
want you know overnight fame is not what
you want overnight videos that go
crazy or you know they often don't have
a longevity so i think patience and
uh the more work you put into it the
more
this sounds stupid but the more work you
put into the more ready you'll be when
something crazy happens because like you
know
some of these guys have been doing
stand-up for 30 years they finally get
that netflix special but their first
hour is
just insane and it's like oh they were
ready
yeah but you take a special too early on
and you're like
hey this is hot garbage but it paid a
mill so
you know that patience of like that way
when the opportunity comes you're ready
i think that
that's great man well thank you for
coming on here and doing this i really
appreciate you coming on
please again promote everything you want
to promote yeah check out my podcast
stiff socks it's every wednesday uh we
uh
we also do a patreon with an extra
episode on fridays uh
just patreon.compod but other than that
yeah
my youtube channel is just where i post
everything that's uh that's where most
people
might either watch this [ __ ] or know me
from but uh yeah i feel like i came on
here and just talked for like an hour
that's what you do on this show cool i
do have a question to ask you about your
youtube videos and stuff so
um the whole like
god damn i just forgot my question now
because you just mentioned something
about the videos overnight and stuff
like
overnight success yeah like um
do you do you
like do you freak out if do you have a
certain number in your head to every
video you want to hit
you don't have to i think so yeah you
have a goal where if it doesn't hit that
number you're like
[ __ ] yeah i think so which is [ __ ] up
because
that number in my head if i had that
number a couple years ago i would be
like that's a crazy number to even right
so so now i really remember what i
wanted to ask you is
are you do you love what you're doing do
you love it i love what i'm
doing i just have to find a way to
disassociate
views from the passion it's like the
most [ __ ]
up thing that'll be is like i make this
video that i know and love i'm proud of
and i'm like this is funny to me and
then i post it in the internet it's like
it was funny to you not today you know
it's insane whatever happened instagram
taking the likes and [ __ ] off they
talked about it and talked about it and
talked about it never
[ __ ] happened they're smiling out of
control my likes are gone i can't see
anybody's likes but like oh you can't
yeah no but like some people can some
people can't i can but my videos now
sometimes the audio will just cut out on
it won't do it on any other
yeah and i watch other people's and it
does it too it like cuts in and out
instagram thing yeah instagram is
[ __ ]
spiraling out of control right now
they're trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] going on because they were on top
of the world for so long
and now tick tock out of nowhere i was
like we're the hot girl now
and then instagram's like what what
about me instagram's like the girl you
see walking around on like [ __ ]
you know from a soho house with ninety
thousand dollars of like plastic surgery
and
yeah just trying to hold it together
what about me you guys don't want me
and uh so it's trying to be like i not
stay relevant because i think instagram
is still very relevant
but uh i think they're just trying so
much at once that they like
it's like you know when you have a bit
that's like half worked out and you're
like okay i need to fix this tag or two
that'll be fully done
and then you just kind of forget about
it i think that's what you're talking
about with like instagram like we're
gonna remove the likes so we can
get ego out of this because that's why
they love it that's why everybody's on
social media for [ __ ] ego what are
you talking about exactly
so i think they tried that and then
they're like yeah [ __ ] that bit let's
try this again
well thank you again for coming on man
for real this was great thank you
pleasure to have you on it's long
overdue dude yeah
it's longer dude as always ryan
sickler.com
ryan sickler on all social media we'll
talk to you all
next week
[Music]
you